so uh uh talking about you know we got
the freedom phone stuff we got people
resisting we've got
now the populist left and the right are
like yo jen sack you're crossing the
line you're losing it
for the longest time i was saying um you
know
civil war of some sort but that was
because we were looking at it through
the lens
of last the last election cycle where
the populist left was very much aligned
with the establishment
now that joe biden's in i was saying
it's the biggest mistake for them to
bring joe biden in because
this will fracture them from the
populist left yeah you should have used
bernie
so somebody who yeah and bernie was
playing ball they would have twisted him
man
oh they did twist him but anyway the
point is now with biden
conservatives hate biden disaffected
liberals politically homeless iw
hate biden and the populist left hates
biden they have put into
office a man everybody hates now to be
fair
he's not the most hateable guy because
of how pathetic and old and befuddled he
is
but no one likes him yeah so now it kind
of feels like
that's taken away the prospect of an
actual faction versus faction clash
and opened up what appears to be
balkanization
so i want to show you guys this because
we talked about it yesterday this is the
chart that we pulled up last time
support for seceding from the u.s to
form a new regional union
the pacific region is 39 percent the
mountain region is 32 the heartland is
30. the northeast is 34 and the south is
44.
so what i did and this is yougov data i
added up all the numbers divided them by
five
and got you know 35 or so percent it's
an incorrect number because
the pacific region has about 53 million
people and the southern region has 107
million people
so 44 of 107 million is substantially
more than 30 39 percent of
53 million i did all the math the full
number is
37.2 million people so i added up the
total populations
then i took the percent 44 of 107. i
added them together
divided them by the the actual
population 37.2 percent of
this country is in favor of their region
splitting off from the country
tell me why it's a bad idea well firstly
we're getting a poll that's only
only pulled like 3 000 people i think
right 2 800 people total
which is apparently like twice what you
need for a representative sample
technically but
it's it's only like point one what is
that point zero one percent of the
population got pulled on this so i
i i could see you know random errors
hold on hold on so what you're basically
saying is that
they got lucky in that everyone they
asked just happened to be the people who
wanted to succeed could have been no it
could have been the way they were asking
the question to like do you want to
secede from the union they're like oh i
never thought of that
the question the question was something
like would you support
your region breaking off from the united
states to form a new regional yeah and
if someone had never thought that before
and then they saw that question they
might be like
yeah sure yeah okay so they support it
like it wasn't like they were like i
want this to happen
and they thought of it on their own like
they're being coaxed into answering i
i think you're attacking the poll which
is it's yougov data yougov is pretty
pretty good
and it's 2 750 people which is more than
needed for representative sample
it is i'm not trying to say the polls
perfect because polls are pretty trash
yeah if it was 70 million people that
voted for something like this i'd be now
this would be
hot hot hot to me well like tim said
polls are typically garbage
um but if you want to ask someone a
question and kind of figure out what
people are really thinking you could
break it down with any question you
could be like this poll is wrong because
they asked it in this way
so i feel like you're kind of splitting
hairs i don't care i don't care about
arguing about whether polls are good or
not
talking about based on this data 37.2
percent of people want to balkanize the
united states is that a good or bad
thing
if you want to ask me why would i
consider it a bad idea which is not
the opinion that i'm going to espouse is
because we've never done it successfully
without
mass conflict but you think it's a good
idea i think that
it's something that we're exploring that
could very well be a good idea
i mean it it's in it's it's we're in the
exploratory stage
it's certainly the better it's a better
option than many many things
i would much rather have peaceful
divorce than than
um what happened in bosnia right right
right you know like
i would rather have peaceful divorce
than the constant riots in minneapolis
being the
new normal that's fair um i would rather
have
some form of ability for american the
current country that is america where
people go okay
you know what then we're gonna we're
gonna finally have the motivation to
move here
and we're gonna build our families and
we're gonna build our cultures and we're
gonna
realize that this ship will never meet
again like this we
we have to stand at odds or you know
maybe
there's you could you could take it in
more cynical ways but
yeah i would much rather have it than
some sort of authoritarian dictatorship
where it's like
i'm under the boot of you know somebody
he doesn't it pick an authoritarian
that's that even holds all of my views i
don't
you know you you mentioned something i
had said earlier in that
biden isn't talking to you when just
seriously when genseki comes out when
biden comes out
everybody listening to the show knows
biden is not talking to them
because he says things that are not in
line with literally what their states
are doing or what their representatives
want
or the people have voted for so the
example easily being when biden said we
need more lockdowns
and taxes in florida had literally
reopened everything to the support
of their of of the residents and the
citizens of their of their states
so biden is literally saying our
democracy and our country
and they're they're actually saying the
republicans are the problem in fact let
me let me pull up this uh
this story from newsweek gosh ex trump
official
says gop greater national security
threat to u.s
than isis or al qaeda the grand old
party
the republicans so when joe biden comes
out and says
what the republicans are doing is the
biggest threat since the civil war
you know he is already saying this
country
is not unified and they are the enemy
well it also it also goes back to your
point is he saying that
and this is where you have to make a
really important parsing is he saying
that
the republicans are the biggest threat
to the country or to his
regime and i think the answer is b
no i think he's saying country and i
think he views the country as only his
supporters and only his states right
exactly say we're splitting hairs in the
conversation i agree with you yeah
so what does that mean for the rest of
us i suppose i kind of think we're
already
balkanized the way we built this country
was absolutely incredible we have these
states
with this massive power these state
powers so that's kind of what the
balkans are as a bunch of states
um so as long as we reign the power of
the federal government
i think that we're already ready to go
man we're bo we're balkanized and ready
man
we're a decentralized union of states
um i was going to say i think that if
you look at the example of the balkans
that's not good that's not encouraging
uh we could probably look at something
like the eu and if we go into it in an
organized fashion which i don't think we
are i think that everything's going to
be
insanely slip-shot like the voting in
2020 give me a freaking break
absolute insanity i think that we're
more likely to be more like the balkans
than the eu but if we could do something
like the european union that would be
are you not simple from talking to a
british dude about the eu
he was saying it was really horrible
because it was like unelected leadership
would make decisions for england all of
a sudden that's exactly what i've been
saying about the democrats
yep dude i move out to the middle of
nowhere
because i don't want to live in philly
when i live in philly you know i live in
we live in the suburbs and i hear like
they want to pass certain laws i'm like
i get it that makes sense because i live
in a city i live in an urban area
move to the middle of nowhere now all of
a sudden i'm hearing what the democrats
are doing i'm like that makes literally
no sense because now i understand what
it's like to be in the middle of nowhere
the one thing i realized is how come i
wasn't hearing the inverse
how come i wasn't living in the city
hearing policies about why we need to
legalize raising livestock in our homes
because republicans don't fight for
things so
if you live in an urban environment and
you hear the debate in washington
you're probably thinking like this
debate makes sense the republicans are
insane for denying this
if you move to a rural area you hear the
debate and you're like why aren't the
republicans fighting for what we need
where we live
i think a lot of these young leftists
grow up in cities they don't understand
that i mean
we can't already have it we have it
that's why they're not trying to change
it like you were saying laws get made
but they don't get
they don't get broken apart yeah they
don't get enough maybe they should have
sunset clauses built in
yes there's there's a there's like there
are books called like you know bat
uh like ridiculous laws or whatever
there's like some law where you can't
take showers on tuesdays and like
massachusetts or something like that
some some town
there's laws where it's like you can't
put an apple pie in your window sill on
sunday afternoon yeah
and these laws made sense at the time
but they were passed when there were
like 300 people living in the city and
now there's 500 000
so it's like not being able to shower on
tuesdays was because
they had you know a certain amount of
water or like you know
the the city was you know limited in
some capacity
you can't have you know pies on your
windowsill on sunday because
something was happening the church i
want to tempt them i don't know
not about tempting but just about like
you know just they had reasons for this
stuff they don't make sense anymore
so the so the term balkanization i mean
it's still kind of a newer concept for
us right and so
we're i mean not it's it's newer in the
cultural conversation for sure
um you know it's at least since the
civil war i guess
that would be a good way of saying it
but so perhaps when we're talking about
balkanization we're also thinking about
it in the same way that we tend to
address like
hyper aggressive authoritarianism
they're really like very very
far out concepts like for us we could
move towards balkanization by moving
towards decentralization
and not actually have to reach full-out
balkanization
but and that would be something that you
do in degrees you don't just go okay
cool we're breaking apart here's the
lines we're done
but that requires certain things of
people to do
as citizens like you know agree that we
shouldn't elect people that threaten
their own
population with violence or we you know
whatever like that you could do that
i i think the issue you know one of the
things they brought up in the study was
most people are actually just saying
they want power so
66 of republicans in the south want to
secede
but would they be saying that when trump
was president maybe not
maybe not because they have the power
right now and so there lies the problem
that joe biden comes out and he's like
i will crush my enemies and the
establishment dams are going
yes and they're clapping and cheering
for it that i think is the most
dangerous part
is that is that we are now making it
culturally acceptable to
overtly express from a position of power
in politics while also feigning the act
of being the victim
that we think it is good to do exactly
to exact violence on our opponents i
think it's a very very specific reason
why we don't do that in public
that's why i was saying i'm more worried
about the establishment than like
populist leftists
yeah there's there's there's an issue
i'm saying populist i'm not saying
uh antifa authoritarians and black lives
matter they serve the establishment
i'm saying like you know the the left's
arguments about all this stuff i'm kind
of like yeah whatever dude i live in the
middle of nowhere like
have your hippie commune have your
healthcare or whatever let's you know
if if this if the states break apart to
regional unions you can go move to the
one that better suits your needs
i would say the biggest problem with it
is china that's what i've long said
that china just takes over the moment
this happens they go thank you taiwan's
theirs
what's the history of the balkans anyway
are you guys familiar with how did it
shatter what was it before
it balkanized and then uh what was it
after kosovo i know it was part of that
serbia i don't know see because it used
to be man i'm just i'm not educated
enough on but i've what i got a message
from someone there like i was
in the balkans when the i think it was
the kosovo war and they're like it was
like nazi germany it was worse i think
they actually said it was worse than
nazi germany and i don't think they were
in nazi germany but
it was just like i mean i don't know but
mass mass chaos
it's introduction you know what's really
interesting about this is there's been a
lot of like
legit far-right people several years ago
were talking about wanting to balkanize
the us and we all scoffed and laughed at
the idea
now they have a poll coming up where
it's like apparently americans want to
do this i think it's bad
in the long run we don't want china take
over i mean
we got problems here joe biden's a nut
the democrats and the neocons are really
really bad the establishment politicians
are really bad but
look at the show we're allowed to do
that we wouldn't be allowed to do if we
lived in china
oh i know why do you what do you think
about the american russian
like relations i personally feel like
the united states and russia should be
the most intimate of allies to protect
the earth
yeah i mean i don't know about that two
of the largest land masses on earth
they're not
authoritarian chinese consciousness
russia has more land than pluto
russia's does it really work gigantic
yeah russia is massive but most of it's
a lot of it's siberia but that's still
cool
because if that ice melts away yeah if
it warms up
uh i would love to like preserve the
arctic with like a global let me
let me let me let me tell you something
um i was in moscow once at the airport
when you board a plane in the united
states the lady goes
now boarding group when and you get up
and and advantage members and global
pass or whatever they call it
and then you everyone in this group when
you're sitting there on your phone they
get up and they go to board one by one
now boarding group q and group two gets
up
so um i'm in russia at the moscow
airport transferring i was flying
ukraine
and they announced now boarding group
one every single person got up and ran
full speed like literally running but
like rushing
and then shoving each other out of the
way and waving their tickets at the lady
and then the lady would like just grab
one and then beep and the guy would
squeeze his way through on the plane
it was not boarding by anything it was
just chaos
and i was like this is weird and i
talked to my friend who was ukrainian
about it
and the general conversation was which
she was saying is
yeah that's normal like that's how it's
like eastern european people do that all
the time
and i was like that's so weird in
america we just like group one boards
and you get up and you sit there and you
wait because if you go up without your
ticket they'll tell you hey you're not
group one go sit down
and then what she basically said was
during the soviet union
the people who survived were the ones
who are going to steal the extra loaf of
bread
who are going to surreptitiously gain
extra food somehow or
cheat on their on their you know books
or whatever or get money or illegally
sell things or smuggle
the people who would do whatever it took
to get what they wanted to survive
and now these people are the children
and some of them lived in the soviet
union so who survived with those hundred
years of soviet communist oppression
the people who are willing to rush to
the front of the line to grab that loaf
of bread before someone else got it
they had kids they grew up and that's
the culture that persisted
now it wasn't the conversation wasn't
that was the general idea of the
conversation and i was like wow dude
so there's problems with russia and many
of the former soviet states in that
the soviet union created you know
survivors
it created countries of people who would
do whatever took to survive
and with that comes pros and cons so
what is russia vladimir putin
we must take power we must we must we
must succeed we mustn't give up former
kgb guy
the united states is not like that now
it's kind of being like that because the
idea
because america has been so lacks and so
accepting with all these good times
we let you know wolf fox at the hen
house and now we got the ideologues
taking over the government mark milley
has gone as woke as what can get
that dude's cracked out of his mind mark
milly has lost it
like dudes nuts cultist fully ideologue
that's scary and so you this the
the the i don't know what you'd call it
but the
pragmatic you know um reasonable mind is
not winning this one
russia does not have it and it's not and
i'm not saying that to be disrespectful
but
the mentality of russia is very much
like vladimir putin
there's rumors that he's the richest man
on the planet because he's you know
controls all this money
he's a he's a permanent political you
know president or whatever in russia
it's just
i don't know about all that man yeah
it's pretty disgusting but
you know you know so is being human in a
lot of ways you gotta poop every day
that's pretty gross
yeah but what i'm gonna say is it looks
like authoritarianism is on the rise
everywhere
even in the u.s i uh i would say there's
a silver lining to russia's
authoritarianism
because the countries that remember what
communism is like are going to be some
of the last
bastions of western strength i think
like hungary poland romania estonia
romania all of these little countries
they will never go back to communism
and the further you get i think the
further you get from communism the more
likely you are to repeat it i think
that's what we're seeing in the u.s
yeah yeah i mean if you look into the
you know the marks marxism
is an interesting thing he just thought
it was like that you're talking about
hegelian dialectics and his wiser people
than me that have talked about this
he more or less thought it was
inevitable and you'll also look at
the concept of insurgency which is a
topic that i've been studying more
recently um and it's very interesting to
see that insurgency is sort of like it
preys on the natural weaknesses of
liberal democracies
is what it does yes so like so what you
kind of get is
i think of when i think of communism i
think of something like
it's a fever you're going to get every
century and if you can survive it you
get another 100 years but if you don't
survive it
it takes you know do you see what the
the democrat what black lives matter and
aoc have said about cuba
yeah that's that's that's some creatures
what is up with the black lives matter
praising castro there is that reason so
hold on yes
absolutely it's real they were saying
rest in power castro
mark milly our general supports that
this dude this is dark stuff and you
know what trump should have fired the
guy
but anyway and this is freaky stuff you
got aoc and black lives matter coming
out saying
it's not cuba's fault it's not
communism's fault
it's america's fault i love this idea
because it's so social it's so communist
that
if if ian is hungry it's my fault for
not giving him my food
it's like okay i could help him i could
but ian's food is ian's responsibility
not mine were you preventing me from
getting the food
from getting my food yeah so was america
like
sanctioning cuba and bargaining down
america wasn't trading with cuba
before castro got into power i think
this was mostly having to do with the
communist revolution
but but regardless does cuba have land
does cuba have fish does america have an
obligation to trade with countries that
are actively working against them
no ian what do you got in that war room
pandemic i don't want to tell you tim
well if you i'm suffering and i want it
no it's mine
stay off my coffee my suffering is the
fault of ian for not giving me his mug
that's propaganda
don't listen to him foreign america is
not
giving them stuff it's our fault they're
suffering thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you